we're going to begin in south florida
this morning with concerns that a
tropical storm
could slow the search and rescue efforts
at the collapsed condo tower in surfside
the work resumed last night after a more
than 12-hour pause because
of safety issues at the site president
biden and the first lady met with
survivors and families of dozens of
missing people and visited a memorial
honoring those who lost their lives
omar villafranca is in surf side florida
for us just north of miami beach omar
good morning to you we understand the
president and the first lady spent three
hours
with victims and survivors
good morning they did day nine of the
search and rescue efforts are
underway this morning there are some
storms in the forecast for later on this
afternoon that's something that first
responders will be keeping an eye on
we also know that officials have
notified the next of kin of 17 of the 18
victims
while dozens of families still hold out
hope for their missing loved ones
we will continue to search feverishly as
we have done
all along in the parts of the collapse
that we currently have access to search
and rescue efforts resumed
thursday afternoon after a 15-hour
standstill over safety concerns
that the rest of the building could come
down officials in miami-dade county said
they are planning for a likely
demolition of the remaining building
this is a decision that we need to make
extremely carefully and methodically
alan kilsheimer is a structural engineer
no one really knows
in in detail exactly what the condition
of the remaining building is
we also have a storm coming so we're
looking at the storm and what it does to
the building
could this storm knock the remaining
parts of the building down
everything's possible earlier thursday
president biden and the first lady paid
their respects at a growing memorial
after meeting with first responders the
whole nation is born in with these
families
they see it every day on television
they're going through hell
moments earlier mr biden privately met
with survivors and victims families
for nearly three hours the president
came out and he spoke a few things it
was like i'm here for you
hang in there including steve rosenthal
who had lived in the condo for 20 years
before it collapsed
we lost everything when he was finished
he literally
went to every table talked to every
person
and as long as you were talking he was
listening
it was amazing it really was
fema says it'll likely be weeks before
the rest of this building here behind me
is brought down president biden has
ordered a federal probe into what caused
the collapse and he also pledged
to pay for the recovery efforts here for
the federal government will
for the first month eureka omar thank
you